so my first questions for you Richard
I'm it's a million dollar question what
exactly inspired this what on earth were
you thinking this epic and I don't use
that word lightly endeavour I wanted to
tell a story about childhood and about
parenting and I couldn't really pick a
spot yeah I didn't have my 400 blows
moment you know I my ideas were spread
out over all of it
so I'd kind of almost given up on the
idea right at that moment where you're
kind of okay it's just not gonna work
boom you know this idea comes in my head
well why couldn't you just shoot a
little bit every year and that would you
know this kind of broad cinematic canvas
presented itself I was like oh that
would tell the story I mean that's the
cool thing okay I'd saw my narrative
problem but then I had created another
problem like oh the Impractical how are
you gonna do this over 12 years you know
that's the impractical side but the
storytelling side I felt really
confident in like I hadn't seen that
before and I thought wow that that could
work you know this kind of accumulation
of intimate moments and the tone
everything came to me in that one 1st
through 12th grade all that just we were
grateful to have the opportunity to tell
this story in this way and such a unique
experience you know I'm seeing this guy
you know I met when he was 6 years old
and he sits before he was a 19 year old
young man and you know so it's it's been
an amazing like life project you know
how was Ella discovered did you audition
did your parents put you up to this
I just went to an audition yeah I mean I
had a headshot in a resume at that time
I was I had been in a couple like
commercials and small films in Austin
and yeah I just went to an audition and
went to about nine more so and it was a
big decision yeah yeah I wanted to be
sure and just kind of talked you know I
mean obviously there wasn't there
weren't really scenes for me to read or
anything so kind of just chatted and I
showed raped some of my art
he was just he talked very passionately
about movies and music was a big part of
his life and art and just his thought
process and I was like I don't know if I
was I probably had an element of myself
at that age but I think I was more like
in sports and I've met a lot of kids
like that so I remember thinking well I
want this movie to represent what I
consider the better part of myself you
know like so I kind of went with the the
ethereal mysterious artist kid whose
parents are artists who I thought would
kind of but it wasn't just staring at
this kid kind of going what do you get
who are you gonna be you know what are
you gonna be like all these years from
now it's a it's a big you know I always
make a joke it's like the figuring out
who the next Dalai Lama is gonna be you
know they put out this stuff like who
are you young man you know so the child
performances in this film are incredibly
naturalistic also from your daughter as
well who plays a Mellors sister in the
film how do you go about directing
children do you just take the same
approach with kids as they do with
adults or yeah pretty much the same I
try to include them and you know
collaborate with them I think at the
very beginning a lot of rehearsal you
know treat him like like any other you
know it's a little bit more of a
manipulation they don't have the
experience and but you know remember I
had been a parent and Lorelei was 9 you
know when we started so I'd have been a
parent that long and I hadn't really
worked with kids at that point but it
came really natural to me I feel I mean
right after we shot our first episode I
came up here and did school Iraq so
suddenly I had a whole film of you know
10 11 year olds 12 year olds so I got a
dose of working with kids you know that
this era so but the casting of Patricia
you never worked with Richard before you
have some personal ties to the role I
mean you yourself were a young mother as
well obviously being a parent is your
primary thing in your life and but when
he called me about this idea I just got
so excited immediately
and I wanted to be a part of it and
everything about it was unorthodox you
know he didn't go through the whole
battering ram of agents and that whole
situation just called me directly told
me about this idea it really excited me
and I said I wanted to do any said we
don't have any money and I said I want
to do it and he said I was like oh yeah
what's my part and he told me a little
bit and I said I guess I should read the
script means like we don't have a script
here's sort of you know the main things
your character and the family will go
through and those all stayed the same so
everything about it was sort of like
jumping off a cliff trusting completely
in the process collaboratively working
together I think a lot of people would
be afraid like what do you mean you know
my script how do I know I will like the
tone how will I know you know that I
like what my characters saying I don't
know about this but it always just felt
right the whole thing and it really felt
beautiful and I felt like maybe the way
we oughta work in this business there
was no ever power struggles or anything
other than support I think for everybody
and from everybody
I'm definitely spoiled I like having a
year off after I shoot every three or
four days to think about what's next to
edit just imagine what feel my weight
the only film he made over this 12 years
I mean you know busy over the 4,200 plus
days of this we only shot about 39 of
those and you spent two years in the
editing room on this yeah if you added
the numbers on this film are really
crazy I mean we spent a year in
pre-production if you add it all up it
was like making 12 movies and then we'd
spend about two years if you add up all
the weeks and the editing room over that
12 years so yeah the numbers are
everything about this movie was unusual
in that in that regard
it continues to be Eller given that you
never watched any footage you know over
the course of 12 years can you take me
back to when you first saw it what that
whole experience was like for you yeah I
mean it was
I watched it by myself about three two
or three times in a row I think right
before Sundance and
I mean it was it's brutal it's I mean I
mean not in a negative way really just
it just our sis kind of you know I mean
it it was hard to think much the first
time it the first couple times I was
kind of just like waterworks for a
couple days honestly but it you know I
mean I think it's it's a very kind of
mysterious part of yourself the way you
change over time and and it's also I
mean I think we everybody struggles with
kind of feeling real or feeling like a
human being you know and just to see all
of these kind of parts of myself that
individually might be like painful or
embarrassing or something or in you know
an incomplete person just has all put
together like that kind of in context is
very comforting in a way for me I I
really I loved endings I loved finishing
jobs I love not knowing what I'm doing
next I could be done with something and
move on and last year I was really sad
that we were finishing shooting this
movie and I really maybe it's a jaded
quality or something I didn't want to
give it to the world but like we were
giving birth to this baby and then
feeding it to wolves or something like
these people are gonna understand this
like I feel this human residence I feel
this intense emotion I feel this
incredible love it's gratitude in this
openness about this movie and this
experience but I don't know if people
are going to get it so it's been really
incredible to feel people have and I've
never had an experience where a movie
was so warmly embraced and people are
having conversations about being human
beings and connecting but still as
beautiful as this is I would still trade
it to keep making the movie because that
was really just incredible acting gift
and human gift